welcome back to las vegas now in today's
legal minute we're learning about
personal injury claims eric palacios
from eric palacios and associates the
sponsor this of this segment tells us
more
i'm eric palacios welcome to the legal
minute this week's question is how long
do i have to settle a personal injury
claim we're going to discuss three main
points number one in nevada you have two
years from the date of the accident to
reach an agreement with the insurance
company if you don't you may lose your
right to compensation forever number two
the only way to extend this time is by
filing a lawsuit in court this lengthens
the time you have to settle your claim
and number three although you have two
years to negotiate your case you don't
want to wait to seek medical attention
as soon as you're injured as soon as you
suffer an accident it's important to go
see your doctor this has been the legal
minute we'll see you next week
if you'd like more information you can
give eric palacios and associates a call
with that phone number
four 702-444-7 seven seven seven you can
go to their website as well
ericpalacioslaw.com las vegas now we'll
be right back